that row is dead opens more questions
than it answers what happens next after
the dobbs decision well today we're
going to look at some of the most
pressing issues from trigger laws to
abortion pills to federal codification
of roe and we start with the idea of
whether states can criminalize abortion
the answer here is obviously yes they
can now the supreme court ruled that
states have the right to regulate
abortion because abortion laws now are
subject to rational basis review which
means that as long as they have any
rational reason for passing a law it
will pass and that means that states can
now criminalize abortions before roe
versus wade two-thirds of states
outlawed abortion with some making it a
criminal offense the majority opinion in
dobbs says that women do not have a
fundamental right to privacy when it
comes to abortions and therefore the
opinion took no official stance on
whether it was okay for states to
prosecute women abortion service
providers or people who help women
obtain an abortion that will be left up
to the state and the states will be able
to criminalize that if they so desire
and obviously looking state by state the
situation in many states is in flux
there are 27 states where abortion is
protected and are likely to stay that
way abortion protective states are
passing laws to create safe havens for
people who travel from out of state
connecticut passed a law saying that its
agencies will not participate in any
investigations lawsuits prosecutions
or anything related to abortions
performed in connecticut the state
residents will also be allowed to
counter sue if they are sued for
offering help to abortion patients in
another state
this is in response to the texas bounty
hunter law and new york illinois and
california are debating similar efforts
of course once states begin denying each
other's citizens certain rights this
invites more conflict for the courts to
decide what about comedy between the
states these interstate conflicts could
redefine how much sovereignty states
have in this federalist system and then
there are the trigger laws 13 states had
trigger laws on the books that banned
abortion as soon as roe and casey were
overturned these 13 states would trigger
laws had exceptions to save the life of
the pregnant woman but only five of
these states have exceptions for rape or
incest and if someone becomes pregnant
by a male relative in arkansas kentucky
louisiana missouri north and south
dakota tennessee texas or mississippi
they will be forced to give birth and if
someone is raped in those states they
will also be forced to give birth i just
have never believed that that having a
tragedy or a tragic situation happened
to someone is a reason to have another
tragedy occur so no exception that we
continue to make sure we go forward
there are five states including texas
where abortion is banned and there are
eight states where abortion will soon be
banned and there are of course a huge
variety of different pro-choice and
anti-abortion laws throughout the
country different states have different
cutoffs some are based on viability
others on a number of weeks
some allow exceptions for rape and
incest and some do not and it's only
going to get more complicated if states
rush to ban or allow abortion but what
about the fetal heartbeat bills until
the dom's ruling federal courts had
unanimously struck down the so-called
heartbeat bills outlawing abortion after
the detection of a fetal heartbeat and
that's why states like ohio georgia
south carolina and iowa passed trigger
laws with six-week abortion bans
legislatures did not repeal those laws
and abortion is banned after the sixth
week of pregnancy in those states the
supreme court decision did not say that
the states had to allow abortion until
week six so any of those states are free
to pass total bans if they desire though
the georgia law is currently enjoined by
the court and then of course much has
been said about potential religious
exceptions many states have laws on the
books that allow pharmacists to refuse
to fill prescriptions if they have moral
or religious objections and with the
supreme court's ever increasing
deference to individual religious
liberties we may see more pharmacists
and medical providers claiming a right
not to fill prescriptions for abortion
medication or participate services like
surgery to remove an ectopic pregnancy
and it's unclear how those cases would
be treated it's similarly unclear how
the court would treat a claim of
religious liberty claiming that based on
certain religious beliefs abortion is
mandated in certain circumstances even
in a state that outlaws abortion who
knows how the court is going to come
down on that but it's also possible
continued jurisprudence from this
supreme court could answer all of these
questions in the negative and simply
outlaw abortion
constitutional rights currently only
attached to people who are already born
the debate in roe casey and dobbs was
over balancing a woman's right to the
state's interests but anti-abortion
activists argue that individual rights
should attach to embryos and fetus
sometimes at the point of conception
putting them on equal legal grounds as a
born human being now the theory that
unborn lives or potential life are
included in the constitutional concept
of persons is not particularly developed
and the unborn have never been counted
in the u.s census for example they've
also never been treated as persons for
purposes of constitutional rights
however justice alito left the door open
to fetal personhood in the dom's opinion
in roe versus way the court said that
the unborn have never been recognized in
law as persons in the whole sense the
casey court said that a woman has a
right to an abortion up until the point
which the fetus could be viable and live
outside the mother and even after that
point there are medical situations where
women
would need an abortion to save her life
and and that would be allowed but in the
dobbs opinion justice alito declined to
say exactly when rights should attach to
potential life but he criticized roe and
casey for attempting to draw that line
however alito himself used the same
terminology that was used in row and
casey that of potential human life
without agreeing with it which is often
a linguistic trick that signals that he
actually disagrees with that conception
of it this supreme court is already
treading new ground with respect to what
qualifies as deeply rooted within the
history of the united states or
necessary for an ordered liberty and is
it entirely possible that they might
find that
liberty interests or personhood attaches
to potential or unborn life
six states already have introduced fetal
personhood legislation in 2022 and the
situation in arizona gives us a pretty
good idea of how complicated this issue
may become the state enacted a 15-week
abortion ban but that was before the
dobb's opinion made it legal to ban all
abortions arizona simultaneously enacted
a policy that gives potential life to
full personhood the state's
interpretation policy states the
following quote the laws of the state
shall be interpreted and construed to
acknowledge on behalf of an unborn child
at every stage of development all rights
privileges and immunities available to
other persons citizens and residents of
the state subject only to the
constitution of the united states and
decisions interpreting thereof by the
united states supreme court this
interpretation policy incorporates the
statutory definition of unborn child set
forth in arizona law which provides that
an unborn child is quote the offspring
of human beings from conception until
birth as written the law could impact a
woman throughout her pregnancy giving
the state the ability to regulate how
she handles basically every aspect of
that pregnancy and as written it could
encompass fertilized eggs which would
have the same status as a born human
being triggering limitations on abortion
medications and even ivf the aclu of
arizona and the center for reproductive
rights sued to block implementation of
this law and the court is scheduled to
have a hearing on this lawsuit in july
but if the supreme court adopted such a
definition as being mandated by the
constitution
would presumably prevent all abortions
in all 50 states and that brings us to
the potential national provision of
abortion pills through the mail now over
half of all abortions in the united
states are done with medication which
means that they are induced by pills in
2021 the food and drug administration
the fda decided to allow abortion pills
giving providers the green light to
distribute them by mail the medication
which is used during the first 10 weeks
of pregnancy is a two drug regimen and
the fda removed a prior guideline
requiring the person to meet personally
with a licensed physician 19 states
banned the administration of an abortion
pill by a telehealth provider even if
that person is a licensed physician jen
biopro the manufacturer of the generic
drug sued the state of mississippi back
in may after the state passed a law
saying that only a state licensed
physician could prescribe the medication
in person the state also requires women
to take the pills in the presence of a
physician now the pharmaceutical company
contends that the fda's regulations for
dispensing and prescribing the pill
pre-empt the state's requirements and
generally a federal agency's regulations
have supremacy over state law however
this is another area where the supreme
court is reevaluating this supreme court
is currently scaling back regulatory
authority and reinvigorating the
non-delegation doctrine
all of which could have significant
effects on what the fda can and cannot
regulate and a state is likely to defend
such lawsuits by arguing that congress
did not give the fda explicit authority
to regulate abortion pills and thus uh
there's nothing to override state laws
and then there's interstate travel will
women be able to travel to another state
to get an abortion well justice
kavanaugh wrote in his concurring
opinion that the state cannot ban women
from traveling from one state to another
to get an abortion he called that an
easy question to answer however that
issue wasn't before the court in the
dobbs case and his opinion doesn't have
any legal weight so is he right well
there's actually not a lot of case law
on the right to travel between states
during the dust bowl years california
tried to ban immigration of people from
oklahoma at the time california asserted
that mass migration of indigent people
stressed the state's budget and created
a crisis of health and morals the states
generally have broad police power to
regulate health safety welfare and
morals of its citizens but the supreme
court struck down the law on the basis
that it was not a valid exercise of the
police power of california and that it
imposes an unconstitutional burden upon
interstate commerce in addition to the
commerce clause people might look to the
privileges and immunities clause which
protects the rights of u.s citizens
against discriminatory treatment under
the law of a different state and in a
1985 case called the supreme court of
new hampshire versus piper the u.s
supreme court held that a new hampshire
rule that limited bard mission to state
residents violated the privileges and
immunities clause
in 1999 the court decided another
privileges immunities case signs versus
roe in that case the court said that the
right to interstate travel consists of
three components one the right to enter
and leave another state two the right to
be treated as a welcome visitor when
temporarily president in another state
and three the right to be treated like
other citizens of that state for those
travelers who elect to become permanent
residents
these cases generally say that people
have a constitutional right to move
freely between states but states are
asserting new powers over their
residents we've covered the senate bill
8 the texas bounty hunter law that
allows citizens to sue anyone who
assists someone in obtaining an abortion
and since the supreme court didn't
strike that law down other states were
inspired to draft similar laws
in missouri lawmakers are debating a law
that would allow the state to criminally
prosecute anyone who aids someone in
getting an abortion in missouri but also
if they help the person travel to a
state where the abortion is legal and
obviously there are all sorts of
problems underlying these proposed laws
because it purports to make a criminal
conspiracy out of conduct that occurs
wholly in another state where missouri
has no jurisdiction and the
missouri legislators who are drafting
the bill also want to create civil
liability for anyone in the chain who
helps a missouri resident get an
abortion including people who do the
marketing of an out-of-state abortion
clinic though the supreme court has
weighed in on a similar situation before
in 1975 the court reversed the
conviction of a virginia editor whose
newspaper advertised reproductive health
services offered in new york the court
said quote a state does not acquire the
power or supervision over the internal
affairs in another state merely because
the welfare and health of its own
citizens may be affected when they
travel to that state now states that are
protective of reproductive rights like
california and massachusetts are also
passing laws welcoming non-residents who
want abortion services and shielding
their own citizens from prosecution and
civil liability for example a
massachusetts law exempts in-state
health care providers from liability for
providing services to abortion seekers
from out of state the law prohibits the
state from extraditing anyone to a state
that outlaws abortion and protects
people from having their medical records
disclosed to states
that have criminal penalties for
abortion but just because the supreme
court weighed in on a similar question
45 years ago doesn't mean that the
current supreme court is going to have
the same outcome especially where we're
going to have even more of a patchwork
of different laws some of which are
trying to create criminal guilt and some
of which are trying to prevent it and
then of course there is the first
amendment since abortion will be a crime
in several states some anti-abortion
advocates are already suggesting that
states outlaw any speech that provides
information that might be used to
terminate a pregnancy or encourages an
illegal abortion and there are a million
thorny questions like this that are
going to come up and
it's unknown how the courts are going to
treat these cases and then there is the
district of columbia washington dc is
not a state so now that the court has
sent abortion back to the states what
does that mean for dc residents well
washington dc is a federal district with
limited self-governance under the 1973
home rule act however under the
constitution congress is the ultimate
authority over washington dc so it's
likely that the current democratic
congress is not going to do anything to
restrict abortion in dc where it remains
legal today however a republican
congress might want to end that in fact
representative andrew clyde a republican
from georgia said his top focus will now
be quote ending dc's failed experiment
of home rule once and for all if
republicans retake congressional
majorities later this year they might
decide to criminalize abortion in dc and
that takes us to congressional action
there are two questions before congress
the first is could a republican congress
impose a national ban on abortion if
they take power
well in doms the supreme court implied
that there was no due process right to
an abortion that leaves decisions up to
the state but we live in a federal
system with the supremacy clause so
could congress pass a national law that
banned abortion everywhere in the united
states
well a majority of the court probably
does not think the national abortion ban
would be unconstitutional in other words
they could probably get away with it if
congress enacted a national ban congress
could cite their power to regulate
interstate commerce under the commerce
clause which is often how many different
laws are passed but that would be pretty
easy to do congress could write a law
that says abortions can't be performed
if they use any device which traveled in
interstate commerce or using any
medication containing any component
which has traveled in interstate
commerce or simply that people being
born implicates commerce because they're
going to engage in commerce when they
get older or their parents engage in
commerce
as part of the process although many of
the court's conservative justices have
been skeptical of the government's
commerce power this situation could be
different if what's being regulated is
abortion justice roberts is the only
conservative justice on the court who
has supported a federal government's
broad right to regulate interstate
commerce so his fellow justices could
wind up lobbying him to uphold a ban
they could also invoke section 5 of the
14th amendment the due process clause
this of course is the same clause that
women once relied on for the right to
abortion but congress could pass a law
stating that fetuses are people under
the 14th amendment and that they have a
right to life under that section the
second question is could a democratic
congress
pass a nationwide pro-abortion law
making abortion legal in 50 states
well if congress enacted the law
codifying the right to an abortion
nationwide what would happen
again that would depend on the way that
the law is written and whether the court
would interpret the commerce power to
encompass such a law but here i would be
more skeptical the supreme court could
take a narrow interpretation of commerce
power as we just talked about and it's
entirely possible that this court is so
outcome driven that it would allow
commerce power for a ban on abortion but
would not allow commerce power for a
nationwide right to abortion but you
can't know until you try congress could
also state that women have a due process
liberty interest to an abortion uh that
would be advisory to the supreme court
they would be the ultimate arbiters but
that would put the ball back with the
supreme court again we can guess how the
supreme court might find on that
particular theory but again we don't
know and then there is the question of
all the other rights that are implicated
by substantive due process could the
supreme court start rolling back a lot
of the rights that we've come to presume
over the last 50 years
and the answer is very possibly those
rights have a target on their back
contraception interracial marriage
intimate sexual acts same-sex marriage
all stem from a common judicial doctrine
known as substantive due process
texas attorney general ken paxton says
he wants to start enforcing the state's
antiquated sodomy laws which are
unconstitutional under the current
supreme court jurisprudence but justice
thomas explicitly says that we should do
away with all substantive due process
rights justice kavanaugh says that dobbs
should have zero effect on other rights
that originate in substantive due
process
but the majority in dom suggests that
abortion is different because it
implicates potential life but also the
court engaged in a deeply rooted
analysis that only looks to history and
it's hard to see how any of those other
rights would survive using the same
analysis that the court engaged in in
dobbs and the descent in dubs made this
crystal clear quote and no one should be
confident that this majority is done
with its work the right rowan casey
recognizes not stand alone to the
contrary the court has linked it for
decades to other settled freedoms
involving bodily integrity familial
relationships and procreation most
obviously the right to terminated
pregnancy arose out of the right to
purchase and use contraception in turn
those rights led more recently to rights
of same-sex intimacy and marriage they
are all part of the same constitutional
fabric protecting autonomous decision
making over the most personal of life
decisions the majority or to be more
accurate most of it is eager to tell us
today that nothing it does cast doubt on
the precedents that do not concern
abortion but how could that be the lone
rationale for what the majority does
today is that the right to elect an
abortion is not deeply rooted in history
not until roe the majority argues did
people think abortion fell within the
constitution's guarantee of liberty the
same could be said though of most of the
rights the majority claims it is not
tampering with the majority could write
just as long an opinion showing for
example that until the mid-20th century
there was no support in american law for
a constitutional right to obtain
contraceptives so one of two things must
be true either the majority does not
really believe in its own reasoning or
if it does all rights that have no
history stretching back to the mid-19th
century are insecure either the mass of
the majority's opinion is hypocrisy or
additional constitutional rights are
under threat it is one or the other so
don't be surprised if this supreme court
starts rolling back these freedoms and
rights and it would probably start with
same-sex marriage and all of that is why
there are a lot of reproductive health
charities out there that are going to
need some help and one very small way
that i like to do so
is a company that i work with called tab
for cause which lets you raise money for
charity just by opening up tabs and
browsing the internet and that includes
reproductive rights charities because
they just launched tab for reproductive
health
well because of all of this and that
lets you raise money for non-profit
organizations protecting and providing
access to reproductive health care like
the center for reproductive rights and
planned parenthood i know this is just a
little thing but it's something that you
can do right now from the comfort of
your own home the way it works is the
tab for cause is a browser extension
that allows you to pick the charity of
your choice and then every time you open
up a new tab instead of displaying a
blank page it displays a customizable
tab with a couple of tiny ads and the
money that you generate is then given to
the charity that you choose you can see
in real time how much money is being
generated and you can even customize
this tab in the way that you would like
it and legal eagle tabbers have raised
over 35 000 alone and i know this
because tab for causes finances are 100
transparent so you can see for yourself
how much they've raised and where it's
gone so if that sounds interesting to
you if you'd like to make a small
difference together all you have to do
is click on the link that's on screen
right now or in the description to
install the browser extension and then
that's it then every page that you open
will create revenue that goes to charity
in this case reproductive health
charities so all you have to do is click
on the link that's on screen or feel
free not to as well and until next time
i will see you in court